preparations for Idol fitter are well
underway at this orphanage in Karachi
the end of the fasting month of Ramadan
is course for celebration but with fewer
donations this year girls are sewing
themselves new clothes for the
festivities
last year I received one dress and some
fabric which we used to make clothes
this year we didn't receive any dresses
but the orphanage bought us fabric so we
are sewing our own clothes
Pakistan is in financial crisis last
month food prices raised nearly 50
percent after the government depreciated
the currency and canceled subsidies the
country's largest charity cares for 8
000 orphans and vulnerable children it
says the economic turmoil is behind the
slump in the nations
in terms of cash donations we have
received about the same amount
throughout the whole year that we
received in Ramadan alone last year due
to inflation purchasing power has become
very low the value of money has almost
halved
is waiting for a 1.1 billion dollar loan
from the international monetary fund
it's been delayed since November as the
government failed to implement some of
the bailout conditions and the Eddie
Foundation isn't expecting donations to
increase anytime soon
we used to receive three truckloads of
second-hand clothes shoes and other
items every week at our centers in
Karachi now we only get one truckload
weekly so we are facing problems and we
are worried
for now the charity is dipping into its
savings to ensure children have
something to celebrate this Eid Barbara
angerpa Al Jazeera